your Netflix special jigsaw which some
people may have seen in some may not
I wanted you if you can to just try and
explain the concept of jigsaw or a
jigsaw for life the concept is basically
and I I don't I hate relationships I've
just hate ninety percent of people and
relationships because they are I don't
like liars and you when you're in it
most people and relationships that are
lying to me and they're lying to them
fighting sales I was sick there's a
certain arrogance to people in
relationships that they've achieved
something that I don't have by you know
selling for this other person that they
have a happier life than I do I enjoy
being singles right
I'm one day I won't enjoy somebody one
day I'll enjoy the company of the person
and I want to spend the rest of my life
with them and I believe that why get
annoyed at is by people when they forced
something into their life the force of
person to life because they think they
should be in a relationship which is
what ninety percent of you [ __ ] do
you crime this horrible person into your
life and you post pictures about how
happy you are and you're not happy and I
know you're not happy because you are
bragging about whenever I'm happy I'm
proud about something I'm not on Twitter
going god yeah I just nailed this on the
best of this but I'm enjoying the thing
you know it's reveling in the
experiences so I'm not boasting I'm not
posting pictures of how much fun I'm
having about the thing because I'm
enjoying myself for me you post about
things when they're not going well too
because you you lie to a social media so
you can convince yourself when you look
back in your pictures artificially
inseminating a sense of purpose yes and
I just fear for me somebody who's
confident enough being single you know
it's it's fine but I even I sometimes
feel the pressure of sort of people you
know people in relationships are going
oh god maybe I should be in a
relationship maybe I should settle for
that and I'm barely able to resist it so
when you're putting out this content
that's sort of bragging about how happy
you are when you're not and you are
adding to this idea that being alone is
wrong you're gonna cause people who are
of less sort of people maybe been lonely
longer than I have or don't have
you know a social circle whatever that
you know or you know mental health
issues kind of us other things they see
you happy and you've said that you
weren't happy when you're a singer and
the happiness that you got is from
finding this [ __ ] person and you're
full of [ __ ] and I think it's very very
damaging and if you want to brag about
half you are in a relationship I will
absolutely brag about happy I am being
single and I will win
[Music]